angel has fallen this is a very intense
action film and you are someone who's
wrongly accused of something you didn't
do when you're on the run yeah so so
yeah I was a little bit first two movies
with with Mike banning and you know the
first one was the attack at the White
House the second was attack in London
and this one's really an attack on the
man himself he's framed and it will show
me a very different Mike banning it's a
guy who's who's feeling the punishment
that he's gone through in his movies no
struggling physically and emotionally
and having to keep it from his family
and as boss the president and that's all
used against him when he's framed and
now he's up against the he's got to use
all that knowledge that he has but not
just against the bad guys against the
good guys as well one who yeah so
they're all they're all after him one of
the cool things about this is that we
get to meet your we get to know your dad
in in your character's dad yes story and
played by Nick Nolte and he is someone
who well it's interesting he his
backstory pretty much is he's someone
who is very good at kind of lives alone
in the woods you don't have much of a
relationship with him but it just so
happens that he's very good at weaponry
very good at putting up a defensive
perimeter right this is almost like his
hobby it's the great you had to have
yeah if you're wrongly accused yeah by
by your government and you're on the run
it's good to have a dad who knows the
stuff yeah yes exactly when you when you
turn up and find in the middle of a
crisis your dad is essentially the
Unabomber
yeah then but in this moment you know he
it works very much noted by Ed to our
advantage but yeah that's the other
thing about there's there's a fantastic
relationships in his movie that we
didn't necessarily haven't in the first
two that and Nick Nolte is is fantastic
in the film and it's very moving and
it's very weird and it's also incredibly
funny especially you know on that
hillside scene when I do find out what
his hobbies are when we're being
attacked but yeah we have that scene
yeah from angel has fallen this is where
you're on the run you're with your dad
played by Nick Nolte and you're finding
out that he's actually taken some
precautions
to help protect you pretty much let's
take a look leave
[Applause]
really angel has fallen is in theaters
everywhere this Friday Gerard Butler
always a pleasure
[Applause]